who would have thought that winter could
happen in Russia this non joke is
frequently heard as people from a number
of regions all over the country are
coming together to express their anger
and frustration about a lack of hate in
their homes in their short videos they
criticize the local authorities who they
say have not been adequately prepared
for winter some even appealed directly
to the Russian
president dear Vladimir Putin we are
forced to turn to you for help because
the municipal authorities don't respond
in the town of podol near Moscow more
than 20,000 residents have been left
without heating for several days due to
an accident at the main Boiler House the
heating facility is located in the
grounds of a private high security
Ammunition plant and when things went
wrong that led to President Putin to
order the complex nationalized but the
problems run deeper than
mismanagement it's due to worn out
infrastructure insufficient funding
ineffective governing system and
qualified Personnel shortage the outflow
of migrants which coincided with the
beginning of the armed conflict in
Ukraine last year State media said
Europe would freeze without Russian gas
which was boycotted due to the conflict
in Ukraine this year it seems the tables
have turned as the armed conflict in
Ukraine approaches its 2-year Mark the
system in Russia is beginning to show
some signs of fatigue no one knows what
the limit of its durability is behind a
facade of stability and prosperity there
is a lot of dilapidated infrastructure
and questionable governance anle say the
problem needs to be solved
systematically over several years and
not patched up in a
hurry there's a need for drastic reforms
in the housing and Utility Systems
voters should hold their local
governments accountable for their
actions we can't afford sending our
employees and finances to the war plus
if sanctions from the equipment used by
our utility services are lifted things
will improve gradually the heting crisis
is the latest in a series there are
increased calls by wives and mothers
calling for the return of their men
fighting in Ukraine a sudden rise in egg
prices has also added to home Wows some
analysts say the discontent is growing
as general Frost tightens his icy grip a
woring sign perhaps weeks before the
presidential elections due to be held in
March Yulia shavala aler Moscow